let's start
by talking about the biggest possible
thing the universe sure
will the universe expand forever or
collapse on itself
well you know that's a great question
that's one of the big questions of
cosmology
and of course we have evidence that the
matter density is sufficiently low that
the universe will
expand forever but not only that there's
this
weird repulsive effect we call it dark
energy for want of
a better term and it appears to be
accelerating the expansion of the
universe
so if that continues the universe will
expand forever
but it need not necessarily continue it
could
reverse sign in which case the universe
could in principle
collapse at some point in the far far
future so like
in terms of investment advice if you
were to give me and then
to bet all my money on one or the other
where does your intuition currently lie
well right now i would say that it would
expand forever because
i think that the dark energy is likely
to be
just quantum fluctuations of the vacuum
the vacuum zero
energy state is not a state of zero
energy
that is the ground state is a a state of
some elevated energy which has a
repulsive effect to it and that will
never go away because it's not
something that changes with time so if
the universe is accelerating now it will
forever continue to do so
you